[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you just
Oh
[Music]
see Munich Yasin tactics
globally in Tallulah meetable stuff
come on come on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you just
[Music]
[Music]
singlet you know Christine tactics
globally in Tallulah meetable stuff
come on come on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you just
[Music]
see you later seen tactics
go be in Tallulah meetable stuff
come on come on
[Music]
go be Tallulah need other stuff
Oh
[Music]
come on tomahto
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
becasue Tennessee muscle but as
Muhammad's Luca Luca cannot do you mean
the cord extension coin you clean Iike
cottage autumn a game Mohammad Rajesh
Khanna Yaqui occurs you need
[Music]
I don't know any mega casino anime Sony
naka the same Oaxaca City this is
exciting Tom what do you think enemy of
the year you know I don't play favorites
but you do have a favorite right well he
may said that no don't spoil it that
even she doesn't know the winner yet so
did you like it all
guess we'll find out soon enough
[Music]
sorry Deva Katta cenotes a Souls
kinesthesia
WWE Superstar a dino and amar
[Music]
and welcome to the crunchyroll anime
Awards I am your host WWE superstar and
former babysitter to Conan Edogawa
Xavier woods
aka Austin Creed now if you're unaware
of who I am and you're very confused
right now I'm a professional larper for
w/e okay so I'm a seven-time this is a
thing I do at work w ee e World Tag Team
Champion with with my boys the new day
new yeah and I've been with WWE since
2010 but I've been a huge anime fan for
my entire life
so anime and cosplay is something that
I've really brought to my life at WWE
being able to merge the things that I
love in that ring while I'm out there
performing being able to travel around
the world telling people about my life
and what I love has been incredible so
I'm so honored to be hosting this award
show tonight now four years ago
crunchyroll started this show in a bar
with a small production team and a dream
and now we're here broadcasting all
around the world from crunchyroll
headquarters right here in San Francisco
California
[Applause]
we're live globally on crunchyroll
YouTube twitch and Facebook and we're
making our way to the tournament arc of
award shows and it's all thanks to our
millions of viewers now 2019 was an
amazing year for anime and we had it all
from slaying demons in Kim it's you know
Yaiba to being an awkward teenage
psychic in mob psycho 100 season to
these nominees are also thrilling
gorgeous heartwarming they took us to
our very core Vikings
big people evil moms and girls going
through puberty
20:19 was a great year for anime and now
I want to start off by thanking all of
you for voting and give a big THANK YOU
to crunchy rolls incredible sponsors box
ooh and Naruto slug fest so let's
introduce crunchyroll host and tonight's
voice of the people
Tim thank you
Thank You Austin thank you Thank You
Austin uh how do you do how do you do
fellow Filip fellow kids
I'm Tim Lew host of crunchyroll and
tonight I'm back back at it again it's a
voice of people now I know y'all got
plenty of comments and your heart takes
about tonight's show the nominees the
winners and making fun of us giving our
presentations and all that go for it
give a little Parkers for the twitch
people so please be sure to it be sure
to tweet us at crunch roll with the
hashtag hashtag anime Awards and talk to
me in chat at crunchyroll on the Scorpio
teepee I'll be there hanging with y'all
and maybe even you know interacting with
on you know and I'll be reading y'all's
messages out loud in this very award
show what I know right Wow
so please go buckwild for your check oh
I'm also will be doing some amazing
giveaways so please go buck walling yo
and on that chat for your chance to win
my chats going crazy in back there so
this time around we got fans tuning in
from every different the timezone and we
got seven different watch parties taking
place right now from fans from mexico df
a to toronto so tell me tell me where
you're at is it the US UK Italy Kona
East blue Soul Society just out the
bleach so yeah I'll be right there with
my little matrix matrix a set up
damn I'm going places that's right and
I'll be your voice of the people that's
right you with all that said let's give
a quick shout out to our viewing parties
all the way in Brazil
Sydney Arlington Texas and New York whoa
big shout out back to you Austin fixed
him
so I heard something very interesting so
you have a musical performance later Wow
yeah we have a little halftime show whoo
showing a little video that we made two
days ago so if I was watching this mmm
and that's something that I want to
definitely stick around for yeah you can
you can't if you want to you don't have
to but I'd appreciate it if you do all
right everybody let's break it down like
you know skate breaks down every damn so
it against 2019 gave us some brutal
contenders and this year we have 19
categories where the best of the best
have come to prove themselves our
nominees were determined by two rounds
of voting the first from a panel of 36
globally curated judges we then turn to
you the public who came at us loud and
clear with an overwhelming 11 million
votes oh that's a lot of those so
tonight it's time to reveal who came out
on top and the biggest baddest anime
Awards yet the awards aren't the only
thing recovering tonight either
we've got world premieres
never-before-seen trailers mmm custom
messages from Japan very special award
honoring an influential icon all right
it's time for us to look back on last
year's best of the best it's time for us
to come together with respect for anime
and for each other to fight one another
over our favorites and most importantly
it's time to celebrate the anime we love
and the amazing community that we're all
a part of the anime Awards are starting
now
[Applause]
and now without further ado we're
throwing it to our first two categories
that represent both the look and style
of what makes us love anime best best
character design and best animation
introducing our first two percenters of
the night Miranda Sanchez and Cole
Galliano
[Applause]
thank you so much for joining us guys
there's even more behind the camera
all right so please welcome Miranda
Sanchez executive editor at IGN
presenting best character design and
presenting best animation we have Cole
Gallion from roosterteeth who knows the
ins and outs of animation from years of
working on shows like Ruby and camp camp
huge welcome to the both of you so
Miranda I know you mentioned that you
had a special surprise to share with
everyone tonight yes I did one of the
shows that really charmed me in the last
few years was a very cute story about a
slime a slime that did not want to take
over the world but conquer it with
friendship which is the best kind of
power tonight we have a world exclusive
trailer with special cast commentary
just for you everyone welcome back our
favorite slime buddy Manu tempest from
that time I got reincarnated as a slime
season to come any crunchyroll this fall
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
EQ me sick
[Music]
hi I'm assuming you have a nice myself
you got that was such a nice message
guys I cannot tell you how excited I am
for the second season there was so much
ground covered in the first season and
as of late we've had a lot of ISA KY
that are a little bit darker and that
can be good but then this beautiful
slime brought us friendship and love
into our lives and I am so grateful and
so excited to see what's wrestling story
that's what we need is positive energy
yeah you know good vibes only right
exactly let's get into our first
category Miranda you meet new characters
every day at IGN in both video games and
anime so what is it about a characters
design that that makes them memorable
for you a characters design has a huge
impact on the quality of a series in a
story some are dark and terrifying some
are like goofy and most importantly some
of them are really hot you need to have
good husband owes and good wife ooze
anyway here are the nominees for Best
character design please welcome your
nominees for the following category best
character design Carol and Tuesday soon
a naughty sight though original
character design by Eisaku Cubano cheese
Finland saga Takehiko a Bijou original
character design by Makoto Yukimura
Dorado Satoshi yo taki original
character design by Hiroyuki asada
Kaguya sama love is war Yuko Yahiro
original character design by ocka ocka
ocka saunas on my ko ko' Ishikawa
original character design by Miggy
dr. stone Yuko OWASA
we got some heavy hitters if we really
ran the gambit we got like some cuties
we got some like buff dudes we got can't
ask for I think that's one of the best
things about animes you have such a
variety of design styles and you can't
really see that in a lot of other things
you know live-action does not offer you
that no yep wrestling does but seriously
uh who's our winner
all right and let us see the first
winner of our first anime words of the
year goes to Satoshi Eva taki for
Thoreau
[Applause]
s'okay thoughts do you think that was do
you think they were gonna win this was a
tough one but this is one of the
frontrunners for me honestly yeah
surprise for me like I like seeing it up
in that more like kind of retro look
yeah but modernizing it yeah and the
original version it was a little bit
more cute and I think this really set in
that darker tone that you have like
there's a light hardness to it right and
this design just really did a lot for
the show nice perfect well we have our
first winner
and the first award is down so let's see
what the chat thinks Tim what you got
let us see what what the chat thinks cam
could you move your leg yes we're a user
at axilla XLR oh yes I love the way Doh
doh-doh adapt attest cos designed to a
more modern aesthetic back to you don't
look at me so huge win for the night
Cole as someone who has worked with
animation for five years now what do you
consider good animation what are the
things that you need you know I think
all the nominees are strong contenders
in animation this category but there's
some key factors you have to ask
yourself does it pull me into the action
does it amplify the storytelling if you
can get that in it then you've got a
winner so let's go ahead and see the
nominees please welcome your nominees
for the following category best
animation
mob psycho 100 season two bones
sadhas' on my mapa
attack on titan season 3 wit studio
Finland saga wit studio
demon slayer komatsuna Yaiba UFO table
fate grand order absolute demonic front
Babilonia clover works
all right so thoughts I'm a I'm a
Bigfoot
I love faith oh I always would baby
okay fair fair I just love mom he's so
strong he grew so much yes I'm very
attached very much and I think they did
so much the season bones us so such
great animation like we see a time time
again so much good stuff before I show
you this ooh Tim can we see what the
chat with her prediction is there
welcome to my TED talk I'm gonna give
you guys a little graph right now BAM
you see that graph right there you see
on the green no surprise demon slayer
you know can that's no yo is leading
then second place is attack on Titan
season three with mom psycho season two
as a close third - all right but you
know what enough about me okay I kiss
mommy I need to know who won best
animation Cole best animation mob psych
a 100 buh
[Applause]
good go so thoughts on the winner makes
sense there was so much such great
animation and obviously the people said
you photo bowl Demon Slayer so good oh
yeah they're our season finale where
they fight throughout that entire season
a lot of a lot of good contenders and
everything today but Cole Miranda you're
both absolutely fantastic I don't say
thank you so much for joining us
[Applause]
all right so as we know sometimes anime
is all about punching and fighting but
sometimes it's about holding hands and
cuddling up Anna whoa
dark room with the door locked but boy
see before I get you into it
let's welcome our next two presenters
for best fight scene and best couple
we've got tommix and Jamie
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so our presenter for best fight scene
Dominic's is a hugely popular animator
on YouTube GB are presented for best
couple got to start with ASMR videos and
branched out into twitch streaming and
cosplay welcome of course
Dominic's so I know you're a big anime
fan what do you think are the main
ingredients the best ingredients to have
a good fight scene oh it's got to have
that spice you know it's got to have
impact it's gonna have that flow that
Wow's the viewer and really tells them
that our hero deserves that win you know
if our heroes backed into a corner are
they able to overcome those odds that
are stacked against them or is it just
going to be another plot armor device
random powerup sort of thing yes yeah
let's do let's see the nominees face off
please welcome your nominees for the
following category best fight scene tour
Fionn versus torkoal finland
emperor crimson versus metallic JoJo's
Bizarre Adventure golden win tangelo and
Nessa co versus Rui Demon Slayer key
mitsuno yah
Levi versus beast Titan attack on Titan
season 3 cushy wakamoto vs. TMS fate
Grand order absolute demonic front
Babylonia mob vs. tweet Cheadle mob
psycho 100 season 2
item so what's the greatest fight scene
according to our friends down in Brazil
well let's find out let's go straight to
Brazil hey como vamos vamos vamos
I'm sorry if I brutalize it let's do it
to you guys over in Brazil what's poppin
love it maybe this ad was great
fantastic fantastic guys are looking
great Brazil yeah mwah you guys are you
guys a fan diddly testicle right
Dominique thumb eek it's all good but
yeah who came out on top well let's find
out
oh we got we got a lot of these if
you're under drumroll the whole time
this fight scene goes to Tanja row
versus mezzo
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so thoughts since you gave us the
ingredients for a good fight scene does
that pass the smell test yes the that
was definitely like one of my top three
picks it was either between that attack
on Titan or bomb I thought this was like
the strongest category oh my god there's
so many good fights a lot of things come
together in a fight you know like the
animation the music and a lot of
emotions and there's a fight this fight
like actually watch it a couple times
oh my god this is the one you're
thinking of when you're like driving
down the road oh yeah I gotta get on
crunchyroll and check it out so we're
done with fists now so let's move on to
maybe something a little nicer like like
the flowers mmm come to cozy up to this
year's best couple G B what you got for
us writing a good character is hard then
writing a good couple is twice the
challenge the best anime couples out
there remind us of the beautiful way we
can connect with one another and this
year's nominees are no different
please welcome your nominees for the
following category best couple Kaguya no
Mia and Mookie she doggone it Kaguya
sama love is war [ __ ] honma and kozo a
Matsumoto [ __ ] Rica zona Zaki and shewn
Amagi
Oh maiden Zin your savage season yamir
and historia attack on Titan season 3
mafia Sato and Ritsuko Oh a no Yama
given Baio and ma boo but let's check on
the fan prediction before we meet our
winner Tim yes it's me Tim hi so welcome
back to my TED talk let's pull up
another graph to see who thinks who's
gonna be the best couple we have this
great love heart graph that you can't
really tell who's winning me and Mookie
sugar Ghani you can clearly see that but
then honestly you Mir and Todd oh that's
kind of it's kind of hard to tell on
this uh and this love heart graph but
you know what
it's fantastic love is in the air we
love to see it so JB also I do have to
say um I love you guys some other videos
watch them fall asleep older thank you
incredible let's get some soon the chat
right now hey let's pop it ok enough
talking let's find out what if her best
couple is a copy Osama
love is warrant
[Applause]
we got some in the chat honestly I feel
like that's an appropriate winner love
is in the title oh I love this win
because there they would hate to know
that they won this award they are like
the best couple is not even a couple
like get it away from that's an amazing
win and the entire series is just oh my
god
their relationship is yeah alright so
thank you so much both of you for being
on Dominic's and GB it was a blast
talking to you and doing all this
business net wraps up our best fight
scene and best couple award so thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
so it comes to this hmm through the most
hotly debated categories it's time to
welcome our presenters for best girl
whoa and best boy yeah
please welcome Kara please and Connor
Cahoon
[Music]
those butterflies I know what you guys
should have been in best couple welcome
to the show guys these two categories
are some of our top voted by the
crunchyroll community so we had to bring
two of our favorite creators from her
stunning cosplay on Instagram to her
excellent music videos on YouTube our
presenter for best girl is the
multi-talented Kara please and
presenting for best boy Connor Cahoon is
a youtube voice actor and comedian who
sometimes uses his powers for evil oh so
when you're using your powers for evil
mm-hmm
like how evil are we talking you've
taken over the world are you more like a
lot of really uncomfortable moments for
the viewer you know like a lot of like
oh god you know the good stuff yeah yeah
we all need to do it well before we get
going we've got a new sick game premiere
from a familiar face
[Music]
[Music]
that looks incredible
Naruto slugfest is the first mobile MMO
game starring our favorite orange ninja
you'll get to choose your own character
and Splore the world of Naruto with your
favorites as you fight through the story
arcs of Naruto Shippuden and I cannot
wait to go home and protect my ninja way
so do not touch don't do it oh my Jitsu
that's my job it's custom its DLC later
in the yeah Naruto slugfest is coming at
you this spring but pre-registration
opens February 19th so make sure you
pre-register for the game thoughts have
to see in that trailer another mobile
game to ruin my life with I suppose I'm
already gone down that hole to fall well
ok so we've got some best to get you
Kira how do you know when a character
qualifies for best girl you know I could
say she's nice or smart or strong or
something like that but to me I feel
like the best girl is something you know
in your gut you know when you see her on
the screen or you see her on however
you're watching you just know that's the
person you care most about that you love
for that you want to support so let's
see our best girl nominees please
welcome your nominees for the following
category best girl
mizuka quemado demon player she met - no
yachts
chica Fujiwara Kaguya cyma love is war
ruff Thalia the rising of the shield
hero
Emma the promise never laughs
kohaku dr. stone
Carol Carol and Tuesday
mmm
so what are you guys thinking mezack oh
okay that's all
Connor got any thoughts I don't want to
say anything say it say it say it with
your heart okay best mom is Bruno
butcher Adam you're trying you know it
works it works it is yes don't
all right here girl we're taking home
this award okay here goes web Talia from
the riving shield here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't know I don't know I don't know
both of you're very surprised I'm short
fun hey I'm stunned your jaw dropped I
did it was I couldn't believe it I mean
you know kudos I just really thought it
would be nice oh yeah I thought the the
fan-out poor finesse but now that we
have the official winner I have to know
who's your all-time best girl and why is
it Geng Chi from the you hakusho okay
well the reason why it's canary from
hunter hunter it's because I just see
myself in her you know and I have a soft
I'm soft fruit and as a co like she
barely says any words and how can I
relate to heard that much like without
her some of the battles would not have
been won so Nina from Code Geass
obviously the best good one he's like
just of the Internet okay so we got some
really good stuff going on so question
Tim what's the chat think about the best
girl what does the chat think what does
the chat think I know what the chat
Thanks pull up that graph of that chat
thing yeah
so at Sora Kira at 10:00 says laughs
Talia is the best yes character
development and supports can protect the
MC wonderfully this anime deserves more
nominations and you set that up with
your whole chest out so rocks appreciate
that I see if you see in the chat real
quick you can probably see a bunch of
other people are saying oh yeah back to
you Austin a few rigs in there through
Conor it's very serious I'm gonna get
closer to you oh wow okay Wow as a best
boy yourself
you've got to have thoughts on this
category I just okay yes yeah I do
thankfully that's why they brought me
here today whether there are ten or a
hundred or just a normal teen or a
badass gang leader all anime boys are
best boy to someone but tonight we're
celebrating the number one boy who stole
our hearts here are the nominees for
best boy please welcome your nominees
for the following category best boy
bruno gujarati JoJo's Bizarre Adventure
golden wind Shikamaru
dodo kanata Hoshi Jima Astra lost in
space
naruse all Macchio how heavy are the
dumbbells you lift
she Gail mob Kageyama mob psycho 100
season 2 tan judoka motto Demon Slayer
komatsuna yah
there's there's lots of love for a lot
of boys I'm very biased obviously I love
Bruno Brewer a team you know sure you
know just gonna represent I love Jojo
school yeah there's a really really
tough competition this year yeah so so
he's best mom in best boy yes
he's actually it's a rare phenomenon
it's something that can happen in Jojo
is you yeah it's you sees amazing
official it is Tangier Oh
[Applause]
so I feel like as up to right now
essentially no one's had as visceral of
reaction as the both of you yeah so the
results what are you feeling right now
are you feeling but just a really weird
way to smile Bruno is what I was
thinking
crazy I don't know them now they'll it
was a tough competition it's fair enough
yeah yeah I feel like everybody's been
heavy hitters that yeah there's an
argument you made for everything every
best boy in this group usual oh look see
that that's a great answer yeah a
respect we deserve and if you're kind
enough to people maybe you can be best
as well at best boy too so that's it for
best boy and best girl Guerra please and
Connor thank you so much for coming
[Applause]
Tim we have yet to speak more about this
rep group that you have I know we have a
full award show to do but I need some
sort of information about this and you
drop in bars they I heard they used to
call you Fort Knox cuz the bars you got
this is oh yeah we'll see about that one
yeah so I got a little Louisville as I
said a little halftime show yes yeah so
I got a little halftime show happening I
would be a sampling Samurai Shodown in
samurai champloo is one of our tracks
samurai suit we'll see that coming soon
but yeah come on Awards so we're all
looking forward to the show I know and
but before we get to that we do have a
special message from one of our
beautiful sponsors take it away Austin
yeah if you've been to Japan you know
one of the highlights is what snacks Oh
from konbini Isles to the finest
confectioner's you can't get enough of
those awesome goodies but not all of us
can make weekly trips to Japan to go get
them am i right we can't go to Japan all
the time awesome it is so right but
luckily we have box ooh tonight's
generous sponsor it's the leading
subscription box that will deliver the
best and I mean the best Japanese snacks
right to your door so let's unpack some
of these treats with our friends at box
ooh
oh wait oh sorry we're on we're out
we're on no hmm hmm
yep boxing is delicious it's great I'm
just we're so professional right now and
lucky for all you boxer is allowing us
to actually do a giveaway for the snack
box right now on twitter.com what that
is absolutely insane and you realize
even if you don't well first of all
first of all oh you can win on Twitter
yeah you heard that right yeah that's
not a deal go to add crunch all right
now for your chance to enter not a deal
but to steal mmm it's free it's free
free Japanese snacks now if you aren't
lucky enough to win there's still hope
for you you can you can sign up on go go
go to box ooh calm and put it in the
promo code Awards 15 to get what mmm
what 15% off 15 whole percent I'm not 5
not 10 that's 15 percent on your whole
subscription bucks go ahead and do it
box ooh calm as we get settled here now
what we're gonna do in this situation
first off who wants some snacks
[Applause]
oh god this snacks are falling to hold
down less a little hole down boom all
right here we go here we go
so now let's meet a twitch at which that
Oh nice crab dude what we're gonna do
now is roll into some of our bonus
categories that we've got for the night
right so let's take a look at our
winners for best opening sequence ending
sequence performance by a Japanese voice
actor performance by an english voice
actor fantasy comedy and drama mob
psycho 100 season two ninety-nine point
nine by mob quieter featuring Johanna
best ending sequence
Kaguya sama love is war chicka chicka
chicka by konami Kihara best voice actor
performing japanese curry
I don't got no Dada no totally can throw
it under yuuichi Nakamura bruno gujarati
from JoJo's Bizarre Adventure golden
wind holes in the okuda can amass best
voice actor performance English this
world has you Billy commenced this now
for me the rising of the shield hero and
it's the only reason I need to take
glass down best fantasy the promised
Neverland clover work
comedy Kaguya sama love is war a one
pictures best drama
[Applause]
Vinland saga wit studio
[Music]
just good stuff all around and we
actually have a very special message
from director Xu hey about a for Vinland
saga winning Best Drama check it out
yeah it's so nice to hear but a shoe
here too much mass it cannot have er
granted order a new drama show direct
mistake Antonio area toes I must grant
you this book anime fan oh c'mon you
mean funny society s it just got really
Dinah and hiking services that product a
much later so - hobbies no I mean I
don't you know someone in Itamar take
the convention Tony Kojima taurima's in
Tony even more dice you know my against
akuno humanity oh no saki no me Yoko Ono
cotton stereotypes like add external on
Tony beche communist stuff military and
mitigators had minimal holiday together
- not the most fun not on Casa negasonic
arigatou gozaimasu
boom boom oh and a banana cigar no
second to meet a textile she forgot our
uniform I am a pharmacist I mean I stuff
his name Oh Shiva Tony mochila Katara
penny Aria told M asam
[Applause]
man so there's a lot of winners home in
it so me
the thing that's nice so specifically
friendly near the interview that we saw
it's always nice to see people who are
insanely passionate about what it is out
there doing in general to see the
inspirations so congrats to all of those
winners Congrats to all the winners
special shout out to Villa and Sokka
this guy but we've had a good time on
the couch I love it this is great nice
day like this forever I want to but I
gotta I gotta go back to my voice of the
people booths so I got it I got it I
gotta go it's not you it's me it's the
voice of the people don't worry we'll
always have boxy comm to keep us
yeah farewell my brings a team of
talented artists together and each of
those projects needs a director to see
it through and it also helps if they can
have some stellar sounds to amp
everybody up so here to present the
awards for best director and best score
is Tristan gallant and Lily Picchu so
presenting best director we have Tristan
Galan a man who is behind the YouTube
channel glass reflection and an
all-around swell guy thank you very much
and an incredible posture man
great it's the nervous and anxiety I
thought Lily beat you our presenter for
best score has her hand in a bit of
everything from voice acting just video
game streaming to blogging welcome to
both of you
so Tristan yes what sticks out about
this year's nominees for Best Director
well this particular year we had a huge
variety of directors from well-known
names to rising stars and anime
directors are the ones that are the big
the big decision makers they're the ones
that helped to bring the ideas and
pictures that we see to the screen so
with that in mind here are the nominees
for Best Director for 2019 for the
following category Best Director
kiyotaka Suzuki Babylon
Shuhei yatta finland saga
yuzuru Tachikawa mob psycho 100 season
two hetero Araki attack on titan season
3 kunihiko eco ha de Sade's on mine
Shinichiro Watanabe and Montano Bhupati
Carroll and Tuesday all right all right
so thoughts about these nominees okay so
okay the the thing that I really like
about this set of nominees is that I
don't believe that any of them don't
deserve to be here but that makes it
difficult because I want them all to win
yeah but not all of them can win this is
true mm-hmm so then we find out who did
I guess we shall and the winner is
Tetsuo rocky and Masahiko Zuka from
attack on Titan season three
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow and we were fortunate enough to have
two statements from the directors of
attack on Titan Lily would you like to
help me read these okay
from from Tetsuo rocky the chief
director of attack on titan i want to
thank all of you for this amazing award
if we the staff have been able to
accurately transfer hajime isayama 'he's
amazing creativity ingenuity and vision
to the animated format then that is more
than we could ever ask
we hope that attack on titan fans will
continue to enjoy the series and we are
very grateful for all your love and
support
Wendy the Best Director award is truly a
great honor this is a series that a lot
of people and I have worked on for a
long time and brought to completion
piece by piece the fact that so many
people across the globe love and support
it makes me really really happy so thank
you everyone thank you so much to both
of you and a huge congratulations to the
directors of attack on titan we've also
got to talk about the fact that it's not
just flashy animation or a powerful
voice acting that makes an anime special
Lily peach you as someone who has
experience with music what is it about
soundtracks that brings an anime
together so when you hear piano chords
or really catchy choruses that get stuck
in people's heads all day you know
you're in for something good so here are
the nominees for best score that blew us
away with their sounds I just said
they're really fast for the following
category best score Kevin pink in the
rising of the sheild hero
[Music]
keoki sawano attack on titan season 3
Joe Sheena and Yuki Kaji Judah Demon
Slayer komatsuna yah you gokano
JoJo's Bizarre Adventure golden wind
machi Carol and Tuesday Tatsuya Cocteau
Hideaki it's a to me and Yuki
Connie Sokka dr. stone so thoughts on
the nominees
well it's your category fillory okay I
think I think demon Slayers gonna win by
like heroine Tuesday more yeah so
there's that it's always been good I'm
hopeful for Kevin pink and score from
shield hero good at the same time
there's a lot of incidental music from
dr. stone that I really liked
so alright well let's get to it what's
in the box
[Applause]
Carolyn Tuesday yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
damn you did it again
weird we are on camera it's okay Carol
doctor they want yes it did
how do you feel about that see every
again people be more happy hey hey hey
relax there's a lot of animate to be
watched we will watch it all in our own
time thank you very much on crunchyroll
Oh
step 4 except for Carolyn Tuesday which
is on thank you very much this year
[Laughter]
ah yeah now we have a very special
performance something that I have been
so excited for they are known for their
over-the-top music videos and clever
references to our beloved medium give it
up for the anime rap gods tea time and
ex kata from hashtag the God Squad the
Gauss score performing T times track
samurai desu from the upcoming album
that you need to make sure that you get
all day anime vol 2 Oh run the video I'm
gonna go 13 cross arundel
lightning strongest ex-lap game tell me
some need to ride you chillin like an
image on the jab Buddha don't get asked
last unlike piscazzi slain a hundred man
but the side cut up Yoshino X KY
flippancy come protect the guys got
acute possession release my patch open
my once you figure out too far without
an old direction redstone in my veins no
dejection to be chakra Bukka with the
Jitsu something I'll count me you that
Shih Tzu going beast mode after three
hits of lumbar boy welcome to the Tokyo
junk
pegye sex for you to make it right
- Roli shots be cutting the drug that we
cut in tell my my guests to be whipping
okay make a sex drive that Goldmember
like gallo gonna be with their rap
genius sweet red beans for your son my
sing spin their fingers no Red Cross GG
yes that's a blood see for the top like
bullet when the shells flick Kenny Kings
[Music]
me through with his rivals red get
caught up in the vision tsukuyomi Dan
got quite over here with a sense saves
y'all kid toki said he's trying to get
pain well you won resurrection a dead
say and i made that play another century
- when we get in the mix these buggers
also be oh that's a number six boom or
an unholy win the triple hits next guy
to Teeter happy like a myth for you too
get Rex to produce just big cousin is
wrong and we can flip it
on it mega sex 44 to make it Rex to pony
shots pin cut the metro that weekend
sweet
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow
that was incredible well thank you my
god my god I was looking at the twist
out I'm sorry guys for putting you up
with messing up all our camera shots my
bad this is this is really thickened by
oh yeah bangers over here Tim thank you
you are a real hero now shucks
speaking of heroes this is a segue every
anime hero needs an equally good villain
to help us find out who comes out on top
let's welcome our next presenters Mark
Phillips and Jeff food
[Applause]
first off to well-dressed them in here
give it up for mark is a member of the
hugely popular online comedy group RDC
world one it will be presenting for best
protagonists presenting for best
antagonists we have Jeff who runs one of
the biggest anime focused YouTube
channels mother's basement subscribed
welcome to show guys good to be it's I'm
one of the biggest guys with an anime
YouTube channel well we'll fix it in
post art Marc so let's talk about best
protagonists give us your thoughts on
last year's main characters I think that
all of the protagonists are great
protagonists but I am pulling for dr.
stone and Tonto
all the way but once again I think
everybody's great just saying okay okay
but but like my girl Emma no I'm so good
I respect I respect them much she's a
great protagonist I really do just never
gives up oh here are nominees for Best
patinas please welcome your nominees for
the following category best protagonists
Tohru Honda fruits basket
Shikamaru dodo
tangey toka motto demon slayer komatsuna
Yaiba thank you dr. stone
Saitama one punch man season two
Emma the promised Neverland
okay so I don't think you guys at home
can hear when we're talking and they're
playing the videos so as soon as they
should yeah you know I forgot about
Saitama I'm ready to see you I gotta get
to it thank you from dr. stone
[Applause]
Tim I have a question
yeah who did the people think was gonna
take that oh so uh we'll have to find
out pull up that little graphic over
there yeah so we have gear across GC
said every chance I get
I vote Fruits Basket underdog in this
and I want tor to get a win they just
wrote or I know what you meant
forget it I'm sorry that she didn't win
but it's okay with mice and I hope that
you guys are having some sort of party
with like score cards and set to see if
your picks line up with the winners
because that's a fun way to live life
yes so how do you how you guys feeling
about that that win ah you know I'm
feeling great I think everybody in the
category deserve to be there and and
while my heart's a little broken Emma
didn't get it sank who's a good man and
scientifically speaking he is a very
good all right before we move to the
next category Jeff you got something
that you wanted to bring up oh yeah I
have a special world premiere preview to
share with you guys and even if you
normally hate spiders I think you're
gonna love this one
good that's really good okay so as
insane as that looks and I have all
these mixed emotions watching it because
a filled with terror but it's so cute so
cute yeah I don't know what's going on
in my body right now but but I like it
it's enjoyable now as we know anime fans
don't just root for the good guys bad
guys need love to you mm-hmm so Jeff
tell us about 20 19 s best antagonist
great stories are driven not just by the
heroes we love but by the villains we
love to hate or sometimes just love -
from killers to criminals to corporate
pop idols these characters will stop at
nothing to get what they want but only
one of them can win tonight these are
the nominees for best antagonist please
welcome your nominees for the following
category best antagonist a shalad
Vinland saga
I am Agha say Babylon Garo one punch man
season two
Isabella the promised Neverland
Angela Carol and Tuesday
overhaul my hero academia season four
all right where you guys landed on this
one it's a real tough category there's a
lot of like strong contenders there but
for me I think isabella is just like one
of the most menacing and compelling
villains in recent memory and then sort
of on the flip side of that if you're
looking for just pure evil
I'm agus a is so good at being bad she
brought a lot of suspense to the show
but I'm gonna say Gaara just cuz he
fought like 200 people and I we go there
we go yep if the question was who will
win in a fight that's later all right
Jeff okay which villain was the most
villainous let's see best antagonist is
Isabella
[Applause]
it's always the nicest looking people
know they're the scariest to me oh man I
mean she she's she's the worst mom but
also the best mom and definitely I I
think she deserves that one hands down
yeah well then congrats to Isabella now
mark and Jeff we know the winner for
last year but who are some of your
favorite all-time villains well I mean
I'm wearing a shirt based on one of them
I really love Jojo villains and Kira
yoshika gay is just an absolute legend
so is Dee oh he's got amazing charisma
and like his power set is just
terrifying what about you I think meadow
him from Hunter x Hunter was a great
villain he started off very evil but
then just kind of got some clarification
and wasn't really dead like all you
gotta do is have a conversation with
it's good if he doesn't kill you first
but awesome father from for Malcolm's
Brotherhood the conversation yeah the
conversation with Tim what kind of
villains we got in the chat anybody we
need to regulate on don't please don't
fight people on the chat I won't say the
nicest people but they're good people
oh I don't know some good people out
there but yeah so here's what some of
them think about that win right there
graphic on screen yeah so this one is by
at Katy Manor you came all the way from
England blimey
honestly Isabella was probably the most
unsettling villain this year so only
because you can never get a read on her
and because of how calm she always is as
well as a story to her decisions she
definitely deserved the win and she did
win so Katy Manor UK are you done you
done good done good also real quick I
put the shout out so all the way out in
in Canada in British Columbia there's
also a watch party so you guys in
British Columbia Canada that's where I'm
from
really
you see okay a as they say a boot that
is horribly offensive Tim I'm so sorry
I'm so sorry I just wanted let's wait to
make a joke that's the other coast of
Canada that's where they do that hmm the
warm side Canada facts
yes well mark Jeff thank you so much for
joining us out here tonight it was a
pleasure having both of you here
[Applause]
[Music]
alright alright fans for a little
giveaway right now now is your chance
that's right your chance not you guys
your chance to win a limited edition
crunchyroll he may we were giving away
three of these beauties in the to chat
right now post hashtag he may Xbox for
your chance now to win Thank You Xbox
uh sure voice so um Austin should we
give them a little bit more time to
enter you know give them a yeah fill in
let me ask you out
you got you got any games and you got
hella games on my phone
tons of teppan this very aggravating
card game okay
what as far as xbox goes I'm still
digging into Gears 5 one of my favorites
fight through the pain yeah mmm-hmm one
of those guys it's it's good stuff no I
like I like getting online and playing
video games with my friends
oh I wish I had friends I'll be your
friend Tim oh I have one friend well ok
so also you know love love that but I'm
gonna you know waste some more time by
talking about one of our world
exclusives we got ladies Oh sneak peek
II oh but yeah we have the world
premiere of the English dub of corner
Suba season 2 but yeah the entire season
drops on February 25th so get ready
and y'all in the back let's roll it
guys my enemy detection skill just went
off that's probably a teen year version
of that goal and we destroyed the other
day it's so dark I should be able to
keep it busy then while she has its
attention cuz it's dangerous for Meg
Amina and I to use our powers in a
dungeon I'll be right behind you
cheering you on instead of standing
around making noise how about you cast
some support magic get my magic from the
prayers of all my followers that's where
I'm not going to waste my precious bully
power on some I tried but it does not
work on those creatures which means they
are
[Music]
well I thought why did you why did you
say 20:19 was full of fantastic anime
and it took countless talented people
behind the scenes to bring these shows
to life
our next award honors one of these
individuals so let's get to it
the industry icon award this person
brought new life to the worldwide anime
audiences we know it with his work on
the production of certain iconic series
a series with some of the most memorable
moments of animation in the last decade
I'm talking about
attack on Titan George water created wit
studio and brought it from a five person
team in a room with no windows to the
animation giant it is today producing
some of our favorite series such as
attack on Titan the ancient Magus pride
cabin area of the iron fortress and
winner of Best Drama and contender for
anime of the year
Finland saga from wall rose to Valhalla
George wada has delivered us two
larger-than-life worlds with memorable
characters and you can't you can't you
cannot forget the fight scenes
[Music]
[Music]
now if you all would help me welcome to
the stage the man who is getting this
fantastic fantastic industry icon award
and president of wit studio animation
legend George water
[Music]
it or veto says you know what I George
the most mass your ass Christmas thank
you for having me tonight my name is
George Wanda and I'm from wit studio
[Applause]
just so thick they are
hi everybody in Japan I'm here I got it
[Music]
coq10 nomina anatomica esteemeth thank
you so much to everybody at crunchyroll
I'm very pleasantly surprised about
receiving this amazing award tonight
pistachio no China - on so stare me Toto
Mon it's good to create a create Amazon
so stay with us a kiss a cryogenic
rocket a greata
minute on e on tonica's esteemeth i
would like to give my sincere thanks and
appreciation to every creator that
brought to life all of our anime titles
along with wit studio also all the staff
members who were involved in bringing
these titles to people all around the
world and finally to all the employees
of wit studio I want to thank you all
from the bottom of my heart
focus negative sake notes columnist a
cetera no bestow drama Connecticut auto
demolition Weymouth can't ignore
foster character debuts on so stay with
know producer has gotten mo conscious
famous and I'm very very happy that
Vinland saga actually won drama category
this year thank you so much
I'm happy for everybody that wit studio
including all the staff members
[Applause]
Antonia no Yoast SEO hajimeta to kimi to
boku Nyoka kita kita
Nakata qetsiyah so stay as analogous to
your stereo timoni mitosis could Suzuki
master Sichuan Tony madam and I hear
cutter has him out there so no Chima God
unagi
o'kiku not associate ecstatic tuna I
started as a teen on screen at all
Antonio Eskimo famous I especially want
to thank the founding members mr. Tanaka
taki who was the one who asked me to
join him in creating the studio even
though I just shifted careers and still
was not familiar with the anime industry
and mr. koji Asano who continued to
support all of our projects to think
that a company with such humble
beginnings as you saw on the screen
earlier we started out in office very
tiny almost like a storage room with no
windows
it's truly a dream Cano Castillo at of
autonomy imminent attack a tiger eye on
Tony subarashii bisoder a yacht eater
bagged a can sustain us I really wish
that all of our employees everybody at
which studio was able to experience this
tonight with me but I'm really happy to
be here we tossed a co-wash Domino
television is tossed a single key no
kyojin to sake not scream estas sono
toki wa hon tony mu gamma tilde it's
good day today
but could you say more yoga Houghton
dari mafia so it's a good it's good as a
king Accord Aquino funny I started
coming up on Tony rasheeda's so the
first product that we created together
as wit studio was attack on Titan and
and in those days we were also
selflessly absorbed in our work that
it's really hard for me to remember what
was going on because it was a blur for
everybody but one thing I do clearly
remember is how we were continuously
encouraged by the fans so thank you so
much
at all insane juni jamie pacheco sorry
oka Tony's a niche any additional no
commas it wasn't just Union invocate a
hundred attacks on almost zero it's a
king oh it's good he must know there was
a Rococo kuni tomita New York undeterred
I get in there and I cannot even more
famous
so we at which studio is going to be
we're gonna be celebrating our 10th
anniversary coming up in June of 2021
and to celebrate that 10th anniversary
we have a lot of exciting titles coming
down the pipeline so I'm pretty sure
everybody here and everybody who is
watching is gonna be very excited to
know what's coming up toxin or a
psychosis taken a psycho totally master
kundo attendees jessica quarter came
attacks on a fondo cotton is our
territory koto de ukyo more art a
baklava korekara mo animations crisis
came a snow day kawaranai or Ascona guys
must ariados understand the anime
industry definitely experienced many
things in 2019
some of them happy some of them very sad
but with everybody's support one thing
is very clear even then we're gonna
continue to create anime so I hope we
can continue to get your support
throughout throughout all of that thank
you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
on behalf of the global anime audience
for your hard work and dedication to
bringing the world's we love to life
we're honored to have you here tonight
and look forward to whatever you and
which studio has to bring us in the
future
now everyone this is it the moment we
have all been waiting for
we're taking this all the way up to 100
somebody call Regan mmm because it's
about to go down
anime of the year it just sounds so
prestigious you know oh yeah you got to
lean back on a kiss get it nasty with it
I loved him it's great to help me
present this category I'm gonna be
calling upon the forces of my final
guest we have Anthony Carboni Oh King
Vader and seung-wan Cho whoa
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you oh yeah subtle flex a little
it's a little bit alright so for
tonight's final award we have with us
Anthony Carboni host of the Emmy
award-winning Star Wars show social
media superstar and director of some of
the coolest anime Oh modules on the
Internet King Vader and rising voice
talent and master of viral shorts you've
definitely seen all over the Internet so
sorry some someone Troy welcome
gentlemen now this is it we are mere
moments away from the most anticipated
winner of the night and we get to
present it with no pressure no pressure
how you guys feeling great Oh
unscripted discussion oh yeah yeah I
personally I'm excited to see what
there's been some good stuff out this
year yeah what do you how you guys
feeling it's like it can go anywhere you
know so I'm excited it's Carolyn Tuesday
or I jump no matter what that envelope
says I'm gonna pull the oh la la land on
the enemy yeah we'll have to redo this
fix and post all right well anime of the
year what can be said for an animate to
win such an honor this year's anime of
the year will join the ranks of previous
winners Yuri ah nice made an abyss and
devil man cry-baby
I'm thinking about it each have left
their marks not only as Giants in their
year but anime that have left an impact
on the art and the entire industry so
who's gonna join the ranks let's take a
look at the nominees for anime of the
year please welcome your nominees for
the following category anime of the year
Oh maidens and your savage season ladis
Vinland saga wit studio
the promise Neverland clover works
demon slayer he met two new Y bus new
foe table mob psycho 100 season two
bones
Carol and Tuesday bones
No
all right so we got our final six
Anthony mm-hmm
well we know your speak on it a little
bit why I just love it it's just one of
those like Watanabe worlds that feels
like a hundred percent grounded all the
details have been thought of and I just
loved something that has a really deep
environment like that like the best
sci-fi makes you feel like it could
exist and I think Carolyn Tuesday does
that mm-hmm all right
King Vader hmm I definitely think Demon
Slayer well that's that's my vote it's
they've been win some awards and I have
a good feeling all right someone uh I
personally have a bias towards mob cycle
100 in fact when a mob didn't win busboy
I debated just going home we're like
where did he go trash the greenroom yeah
rash property damage
you'll have to pay mob saikhan 100
season two before sure all right all
right okay Tim for the final time
tonight what do the people have to say
dismiss is what the people have to say
let's find out let's throw a little
graphic on the screen oh it's right
behind me - wow that's crazy but yeah we
have all across the world on Brazil they
say demon circum it's know yo is gonna
take the price of anime of the year hmm
Montenegro says Finland Saga and then
Syria comes out of left field and says
now it's mob cycle 100 season 2 and then
Djibouti says now it's kaolin Tuesday
well I was going and then think Vincent
and the Grenadines say no it's promised
Netherlands so that's a lot yeah a lot
of I'm pleased % you booting on my
mother's side I was gonna say you're a
big Djibouti guy yeah personal stay
great great place great place but okay
but also you know you guys out here
right now in San Francisco just shout
out just start shouting our names yeah
just start shouting
[Applause]
[Music]
hiya flora weird it was all Carolyn
Tuesday there's a lot of demons later
okay so before we make the announcement
though we saved a special message from
one of the last year's best anime winner
devil man crybaby presenting science
towers co-founder ahn yong chan give it
up everybody my name is in Youngjae
I was the animation producer for
everyman cry-baby
we were so pleased to win enemy of the
Year at the last cultural enemy Awards
thank you to all the fans who showed
their support for the show image so much
to all the hard-working staff who
brought everyman crybaby to life on
behalf of science at ER I wanted to wish
the best of luck to all the worth
nominees for the enemy of the Year
tonight and now the moment you've all
been waiting for the winner of the year
is Austin Austin go backstage and get
the big award we believe in you got it
shake shake reach down inside remember
your training
okay you guys you guys open that come on
come on come on it's still going it's
not Wow balloons are in here yeah and
there
filled with air the regular hair regular
air and the winner and Amanda here is
David
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you demons oh oh oh oh and
everyone at home we are drinking water
so water hydrate per annum a hydration
relations the demon ruler please stay
tuned for a personal message from
producer you might Takahashi and we also
have another exciting preview of an
upcoming anime 8 another incredible
anime Awards is in the bag and I'd like
to thank all of you at home for voting
and tuning in thank you to our amazing
presenters the legendary George water
hashtag the God Squad but and of course
our sponsors boksoon and Naruto slugfest
from all of us here at crunchyroll thank
you for joining us and we'll see you
next year
have a great night on behalf of the cast
I'd like to say thank you to all the
fans for voting for the emissary Kimi
Taniya as crunchyroll anime award 2020s
anime of the year some of the most
talented and dedicated people worked
tirelessly to deliver the best demos
really meet Aniyah enemy trees to
everyone and the support from fans like
you and from all over the world has been
truly inspiring and deeply heartwarming
I'd like to also thank purgatory sensei
and for creating such a wonderful world
and everyone at the usual table studio
as well as jackshaft for their hard work
and dedication we are currently working
on demos really missionary but the movie
Mugen train and the first feature-length
film from industries where hanjiro
musical James and Ennis care and will
face their toughest opponent aboard the
Mugen train we hope you look forward to
the movie
wait comes to the
screens and thank you again for
supporting the demo Surya came in today
about thank you very much goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
newsela Rita
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ma
Derrida cases esta to Kuroda or even a
bogus our Amanda
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh no gasps Nino de Hory no totally
Kaito a Honda oh my no noriaki na guror
adhikam Oh toy HMO they killed a
Kentucky state oh you know told Amy
Okuda Khurana this world has you that's
my reason for using this shield and it's
the only reason I need to take glass
down
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]